كففت تركيا قصفها خلال ساعات الماضيه على
مناطق في الملكيه والقامشلي والحصكه وعين
العرب ودير الزور وقد اكد الرئيس التركي
رجب طيب اردوغان ان الجيش التركي سيبدا
عمليه بريه في الوقت الذي يراه مناسبا اذا
كثفت تركيا قصفها على مناطق كما قلنا في
ملكيه والقامشلي والحسكه وعين العرب وديرا
الزهور واكد وزير الدفاع التركيه ان
اولويه انقر الان هي من نوعه انشائي ممر
ارهابي والقضاء على المنظمات الارهابيه
المقابل اعتبرت موسكو ان شلنا تركيا عمليه
بريه على الاراضي السوريه الى زياده ما
وصفته بالتوتر
ينضم الينا الان من اسطنبول مراسل الجزيره
عمر الحاج ومعنا من موسكو مدير مكتب
الجزيره زهور الشوج اهلا بكما ابدا معك
اذا عمر فيه
اسطنبول
وايضا روسي من هذه العمليات هذا القصف
التركي وهذا ما قد يزيد النشاط الارهابي
فيه المنطقه ماذا تقول السلطات في انقره
ما تحدثت عنه وزاره الدفاع
التركيه والتي قالت ان وزير الدفاع التركي
خلوصيا كارثه مع نظيره الروسي اليوم اجر
مكالمه هاتفيه يتبحث فيها الجانبان الوضع
في سوريا وايضا الغارات الجويه المكثفه
والمستمره منذ نحو الاسبوع التي تقوم بها
القوات المسلحه التركيه في مناطقه مختلفه
وجائها في البيان ان جانب التركي شرح
اسبابه وابعاده هذه العمليه وان تركيا
ماضيه في التصدي لمثل هذه محاولات التي
محاولات الجانب او الاطراف الارهابيه كما
تسميها تركيا
البلاد هذه المكالمه
في هذا الاتصال دلالات مهمه على راسها
اننا امام عمليه عسكريه باستخدام الطائرات
وبطائرات الحربيه وايضا المسيارات
الاستئناف في مناطق هذه مره اعمق من
معتدنا عليه هو احنا نتحدث عن حدود محافظه
محافظه دير الزور [__] حدود الاداريه
وتبعد 220 كيلو مترا ايضا هناك استمرار
لهذه العمليه والجانب التركي لم يبين ابدا
لاجانب الروسي انه سيتوقف في وقت قريب
الجهود العسكريه وايضا التواصل مع الاطراف
الضامنه روسيا على سبيل المثال كذلك صاحبه
جهود دبلوماسيه من وزير الخارجيه التركي
الذي بينها لنظيره فيلندي اليوم في اتصال
اسبابه ودواعي هذه العمليه وفي لندن كما
تعلم هي من الدول التي تقول تركي ان كان
لديها مفهوم خاطئ عن هذه الجماعات حسب
العمال الكردستاني وايضا المنظمات التي
يتهمونها تركيا بانها تابعه له اخيرا
اليوم ايضا الرئيس التركي وان اليوم
الخامس والسادس على التوالي تحدث عن هذه
العمليه العسكريه وان تركيا ماضيه في همم
هذه ضربات الجويه وانها مستعد بعمل بري
اذا توافرت الشروط الملائمه او اذا تحقق
تحقق الاهداف في تركيا من وراء هذه العمل
نستمع الى ما قاله اليوم
بس سوري يعني الكوزينه
قوتنا المسلحه والطائرات الحربيه تدمر
اوكار الارهابي بعملياتها في شمال العراق
وسوريا وهي الاماكن التي تم فيها التخطيط
للعمليات الارهابيه في تركيا هناك اعضاء
برلمان غير مرتاحين لهذا الامر اقول لهم
اننا سنكون حيث يكون الارهاب من خلال
مخابراتنا وقواتنا المسلحه لن نوقف كفاحنا
ضد الارهاب الذي يستهدف بلادنا سواء كان
داخل تركيا او خارجي»
ابقى معنا عمر نذهب الى زور الشوش في
موسكو هل واضح كيف ستتعاطى موسكو مع هذا
الخيار التركي
الامنيه
كهاجس كبير بالنسبه
لتركيا اليوم في السنه في نهايه المباحثات
السوريه في اطار منصه السنه المبعوث
الروسي الى سوريا قال انه اجر مباحثات
موسعه
همم نائب وزير الخارجيه التركي ونظيره
ايضا الايراني ركز بدرجه الاولى على
العمليه العسكريه التركيه في شمال سوريا
حاول اقناع الاتراك كما جرت الامور عليه
منذ عده اشهر بعد عدم الدخول بعمليه
عسكريه لما يمكن ان يؤدي الى تصعيد الوضع
ليس فقط في شمال سوريا ولكنها ايضا اتهم
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه بانها تقف
وراء التصعيد الاخيره ان كان من قبل
الفصائل الكرديه التي برايه تستهدف من
ايران وتسعى دكتور داخل ايران وايضا بدفع
همم الفصائل الكرديه في شمال سوريا اليوم
همم لاثاره الفوضى داخل تركيا في اشاره
مباشره الى طلوع عن حزب العمال الكردستاني
في هجمات اسطنبول الاخيره ولكن طبعا
بالنسبه لموسكو تعتقد ان الاتفاقيات
الموجوده الان بين روسيا وتركيا يجب
الحفاظ عليها رغم التباين في همم فهم
وتنفيذ هذا الاتفاق لروسيا التزاماتها
متعلقه بدفع الاكراد لبعد اكثر من 30 كلم
على الحدود همم تركيا وعدم استهداف
الاراضي تركيا وايضا مشكل طبعا تركيا
لديها التزامات فيما يتعلق بمنطقه ادلب
وتنفيذ الاتفاق في هذا همم الشاعر ولكن
المتحدث باسمه وزاره الخارجيه الروسيه جدد
رسميا الموقف الروسي الذي ترى فيه انا
القيام بعمليه عسكريه على الشمال في شمال
سوريا سيؤدي الى زياده التوتر في كل
المنطقه ويوسع ايضا من الهاجس هاجس
العمليات الارهابيه للجميع رغم التفهم
موسكو اليهوائج تركيا الامنيه لنستمع
لمقالته الزخرفه في هذا الصدد
مع الجانب التركي بشان القضيه السوريه
ونتفهم خوف تركيا المتعلقه بتهديد امنها
القومي لكننا في الوقت نفسه نعتقد ان
اجراء عمليه بريه على الاراضي السوريه لن
يؤدي الا الى زياده التوتر في المنطقه
وزياده النشاط الارهابي ان افضل طريقه
لتسويه جميع القضايا الامنيه في المناطق
الحدوديه هي الحوار المباشر بين السلطات
التركيه والسوريه